[Music]
alright people were taking a break from
politics this week and we're gonna focus
on the f-word that's right
food they say you are what you eat and
if that's true a lot of us are half hot
dog half pizza and half ice cream I know
that that's three-halves but we're a
pretty fat group of people these days
every week there's a new diet to follow
a new oil to avoid or a new superfood
that'll change your life then the week
after that we usually find out that the
new revolutionary diet will actually
make you gain weight you actually need
that oil to live and the superfood does
absolutely nothing and an endless slew
of magazines to the countless websites
and blogs devoted to keeping you
clicking on the newest fad and it
becomes almost impossible to figure out
what you should eat as those of you who
follow me on social media know I'm in
the midst of a little diet myself right
now
I'm doing a slow carb paleo diet which
is a slightly modified version of what
former Rubin Report guests Tim Ferriss
helped popularize basically I'm eating
only meat fish and veggies with no sugar
and very limited carbs I'm even putting
grass-fed butter in my coffee to get an
extra boost of fat and energy in the
morning as of taping this direct message
I've lost about 5 pounds in 10 days
although I've also punched four random
strangers on the street for looking at
me the wrong way but as they say
everything in moderation of course what
you should or shouldn't put in your body
isn't just about weight it's also about
your mind and this is a place where the
science is actually pretty solid the
foods that we eat or don't eat can have
a tremendous effect on our brain itself
right down to our ability to think as
we've seen a spike in degenerative brain
diseases such as Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's disease which are just two
of the many forms of dementia it's
becoming clearer and clearer that
fueling our brains with the right foods
and avoiding the wrong ones are a key to
brain health so much of what we talk
about on this show is related to clear
and critical thinking well we may not
think about how the food that we eat is
affecting our brains on a daily basis
feeding our brains the right foods is as
important actually possibly more
important than feeding our brains the
right information so this week we're
going to learn
some information on what we should feed
our brains so that we're optimized to
engage in intellectual battles in the
best way possible joining me to discuss
this is an old friend of the show and
author of the new book genius foods max
Luger veer now excuse me while I put
grass-fed butter on an avocado sprinkled
with goji berries joining me today is a
truth seeker a self experimenter of
brain food expert and author of the
upcoming book genius foods max Luger
beer welcome back thanks so much for
having to the Rubin report this is a
back although most of my audience now
will not know you from the Rubin report
but you used to do the old Rubin report
seems like a real lifetime ago doesn't
it yeah yeah back back in the day when
it was a panel show it was a panel show
years ago on tea uit I don't even know
what we were doing I have almost no
recollection of my life at that time
it's you know the every time that I was
on it though I would always have such a
good time and I always would think to
myself like how good you are at what you
do and so I'm just so honored to like be
here in this new set and to see your
success like you know the fact that
you've just blown up it's awesome cool
well thank you and I feel the same and
I'm glad that our pads have sort of you
know been on parallel tracks kind of
growing together you have a new book
coming out which we're gonna talk about
shortly the last time I saw you though
it was about two or two-and-a-half years
ago you had me eat some really nasty
stuff on camera that you felt I don't
even know why you had me eat it but you
wanted me to what what did we eat yeah
because you're doing a lot about food
yeah so you're you're testing this stuff
out all time we ate natto
which is a fermented soy bean dish that
is very commonly consumed in Japan and
that was my first time ever trying it
because I think yeah back where your old
set was we were like a few blocks away
from like a Japanese market yeah yeah
and I was like wow what a great place to
go and try to find this food that I've
heard so much about because of its
purported health benefits but I'd never
tasted it and it's known for being
particularly gnarly like it smells like
dirty socks yeah
and I knew that you were back at the
studio and I was like what you know
there's no better time to try this
gnarly food than with my friend dave
rubin so i brought it back and we tried
it and yeah i don't think you were that
into it it was pretty nasty yeah I mean
I'm a pretty open eater and we're gonna
get a lot into the different types of
things that you should be eating and
fermented food obviously good but it was
kind of like beans in this gooey sticky
sauce and it stunk to high hell it's got
the cool you're saying it was good for
my brain it's very good it's very good
yeah there's I mean you know it's the
top known source of vitamin k2 which is
a really important vitamin for vitamin
for maintaining calcium homeostasis in
the body basically keeping calcium in
the parts of your body where calcium
should be yeah like your bones in your
teeth and out of your soft tissues like
your kidneys and your arteries and stuff
like that there's really good research
on vitamin k2 and yeah just you know
natto is one of these foods they eat it
and you know one of the world's Blue
Zones so I just figured why not give it
a try yeah I would say it has the
consistency of like baked beans with a
little bit of like personal lubricant
that's world together yeah which is
obviously not appealing it's that sounds
quite horrific that you had something
here for you to taste on camera don't
even awesome like kicking the ball back
yeah something like that alright maybe
maybe next time alright so first I
thought well we start off with before we
get to the book is I think sort of what
you're doing is interesting because it
kind of parallels what I'm doing here
where we're watching mainstream media
crumble and people are coming to people
like me perhaps and and Shapiro and Joe
Rogan and all these alternate voices to
hear about news and I also think that's
happening in the food world and the diet
world as well where you used to maybe
watch the nightly news to find out what
you're supposed to eat what the latest
fad is what all's you're not supposed to
have it cetera et cetera and now people
are going to people like Joe Rogan who I
just mentioned Tim Ferriss people like
you did you sort of see that thing
coming and that's why you started
getting into this world and we'll talk a
little bit about your the personal
reasons why you got into just a sec yeah
no yeah I mean it's it's an amazing
point I feel that you know look we live
in a time you know and in a world where
we have all of the world's information
at our fingertips at any given time with
our smartphones you know
and research is out there information
wants to be free so you know whereas
prior generations I feel like you know
could have could have only received
health information from the doctor or
nutrition information from the
nutritionist today you know I think
things are different where people that
are passionate and that do their
homework in a way I'm not just talking
about going to you know media for their
health information but you know PubMed
is something that anybody can search
it's that you know the research is out
there not everybody's gonna be qualified
to the degree that they can you know
understand for example medical
literature or even cut through the
jargon but there's a lot that people can
glean from what is readily available I
mean one of the ways that I try to tell
people to become educated about health
and science and research is to look at
websites that put out university press
releases that often accompany studies
like science daily for example or
medical express you know oftentimes when
a study is released the University will
write a press release that basically has
the gist of what the study basically
found in layman's terms and that's often
what journalists will use to write
pieces for like the Huffington Post or
Fast Company so what I tell people is to
do is cut out the middleman go to the
press releases read them then go to the
research article compare what you read
in layman's terms in the press release
to the research article and that can
actually help you interpret research so
the average person though obviously
you're not gonna do all that legwork and
I think that's where someone like you
comes in going I will sit down read all
this stuff yeah and now distill it to
you in a way that makes some sense yeah
well my background I mean you know
before before really diving into health
and nutrition and fitness I was a
journalist you know at Current TV which
was my first job out of college and so
getting to work with the journalists
there you know Peabody award-winning
journalists award-winning storytellers
it gave me a sense of how to ask
questions how to pick my sources and
then when I became interested in
nutrition and health you know I kind of
knew not only where to look but how to
look and and yeah and you know my unique
job gave me the time and the ability and
you know my personal circumstances yeah
and so yeah I don't expect everybody to
do
their own research but I do think that
people should do their own research I do
think that the the you know healthcare
healthcare is something that we like to
pretend that we're able to sort of
offload to our healthcare providers
right but you don't go to a doctor to be
healthy you go to a doctor to become
free of disease or to have a disease
treated I think health care really is
something that you know starts in the
kitchen and in the gym and it's
something that we you know that we have
to in you know and view our lives with
day to day yeah and I wanted to start
with that because I think it sets the
table properly because I know on YouTube
there's a million people talking about
health and diets and all that stuff and
I want people to understand that you're
somebody that I know has been in this
for a long time actually doing the
research so let's go to that that
personal circumstance part that you
mentioned you sort of got into this it's
probably only about five years ago you
with the circumstances with your mom and
all yeah yeah so when I left Current TV
to sort of figure out where I was gonna
go with my career it was sort of in that
downtime in between jobs that my mom
started displaying very strange symptoms
that I couldn't explain I mean memory
you know problems with her memory she
complained of brain fog and she also had
changes to her gait that were very
apparent I mean my mom is a spirited New
Yorker and New Yorkers walk very fast
they walk everywhere and my mom ran a
business so cognitively she was always
very sharp and essentially what we what
we saw is that my mom's cognition took
like a it just seemed to have like you
know like a web browser with too many
open tabs is how I described it you know
just you know like a stuttering frame
rate on a YouTube video with a poor
internet connection and my mom's gate
changed where you know before she was a
very fast Walker
she almost developed sort of like a
shuffle and both of these strange
symptoms seemed to come on at once and I
had no prior family history of any
neurodegenerative disease you know
dementia to me was not a term that I was
familiar with I didn't know what else hi
MERS disease was actually when I thought
about the word dementia you know I
thought about that character from The
Addams Family movie you know like it was
like cousin it's or Fester's like a rush
or something her name was dementia which
was actually pretty fun
but yeah so coinciding with like my
ignorance I had the time to go with my
mom to some of the top neurology
departments in the country we were very
fortunate to be able to do that we went
to you know NYU Columbia and New York
Johns Hopkins in Baltimore the Cleveland
Clinic all in hopes of trying to find
some kind of diagnosis for my mom to see
what was going on and it was in 2011 at
the Cleveland Clinic where my mom was
diagnosed with a neurodegenerative
disease for the first time and she was
prescribed drugs for both Parkinson's
disease and Alzheimer's disease and at
that moment I mean my world pretty much
stopped like I it was I'm a pretty chill
guy that that weekend or that week in
Cleveland it was the first time in my
life that I'd ever had a panic attack I
was just so freaked out by the
possibility that my mom had this fatal
disease for which there is no cure or
particularly meaningful treatment and I
basically became unable to think about
anything else let alone my career I
ended up you know my mom started taking
the drugs I ended up coming back to LA
to try to you know look for jobs and do
what it is that you do when you live in
LA and you're a journalist on TV and I
basically became unable to think about
anything other than nutrition you know
every waking minute that I wasn't you
know doing something career related I
was in PubMed digging through the
research and what I think really
motivated this journey from you was the
fact that what I uncovered in the
research was a stark contrast to the you
know what neuroscientist Norman Doidge
calls neurological nihilism to the to
the despair and bleakness that I
experienced in those doctors offices
with my mom yeah can you describe what
that is yeah what are they actually
telling you well the despair yeah so I
call it diagnosed and audio's you know
basically there's a there's a there's a
quote that I learned that is circulated
amongst medical school medical school
students that neurologists don't treat
disease they admire it that's because
the brain is a mystery for the most part
I mean we know quite a bit about the
brain which is surprising
there's a lot more unknowns than notes
at this point and treatments for
neurological diseases are very limited
you know no there's no approved drug for
Alzheimer's disease that has a disease
modifying treatment they only act as
band-aids like chemical band-aids
essentially that work to sort of
artificially boost neurotransmitters in
the brain but they do nothing to solve
the underlying pathology and you know
drug trials are notoriously bad flies
are just announced for example that
they're gonna stop pursuing
pharmaceutical treatments for
Alzheimer's disease because treating the
quest to find a drug to treat the
disease has like a ninety nine point six
two percent fail rate that's worse than
any other you know disease so meaning
that they're getting out of the game
altogether they view this as something
that can't be solved yeah via drugs I
mean that sounds incredible I don't know
how often that happens with other
diseases right that sounds that sounds
pretty staggering yeah I mean another
huge pharmaceutical company basically
recently announced this ain't the same
thing axe event yeah it's a massive fell
rate so think about it from like the
perspective perspective of an investor
you know are you gonna invest in an
Alzheimer's or in any drug trial that
has you know a ninety nine point six
percent fail rate it's you know it's
just not a smart investment and that's
why Alzheimer's disease research is
criminally underfunded or I shouldn't
say criminally it makes sense although
it's tragic because you know if there
was a pill tomorrow that I could give my
mom that would help in a meaningful way
of course I wouldn't want it I wanted
for all the five million people in
America that are suffering from
Alzheimer's disease well I'm just saying
you know because I can bring almost
anything back to politics it's like this
is a good argument for a publicly funded
scientific research because it doesn't
have to deal with the bottom line where
you're saying yeah these companies they
have to deal with the bottom line and
shareholders and they have to then stop
at some point if they can't get far
enough where something publicly funded
they can keep going to the science
hopefully although you found that there
are some other ways to deal with this
and that's that's really what changed
your life yeah so I you know I so on the
one hand I became really interested in
learning about diet you know potential
diet and lifestyle interventions
that I could throw my mom's away to sort
of help her but then at the same time I
became really conscious of my own brain
health because I learned that changes
begin in the brain decades before the
first symptom of Alzheimer's disease
which is just one form of dementia but
even Parkinson's disease by the time you
show your first symptom of Parkinson's
disease half of the neurons involved in
movement in that part in the part of the
brain associated with Parkinson's
disease are already dead so these are
not you know like any chronic disease
these are not diseases that develop
overnight they take years if not decades
to develop and I became really
interested in doing what I could do in
my own life to maximize my brain health
so that I might not have to deal with
what it is that my mom is dealing with
well go from there and will slightly
shift to your book and obviously this is
all intertwined this is the advance copy
the book comes out in a couple weeks and
I was reading a little bit and I just
thought that the opening alone was was
really perfect so I'm just gonna read
the opening paragraph
unless do you want to read it in your
own voice maybe maybe you should you
know what okay I'm gonna let you read
the reading paragraph of your book oh
man I thought it was pretty beautiful
thank you so much
nestled within your skull mere inches
from your eyes are eighty six billion of
the most efficient transistors in the
known universe this neural network is
you running the operating system we know
is life and no computer yet conceived
comes close to its awesome capabilities
forged over millions and millions of
years of life on earth your brain is
capable of storing nearly eight thousand
iPhones worth of information everything
you are do love feel care for longed for
and aspire to is enabled by an
incredibly complex invisible symphony of
neurological processes elegant seamless
and blisteringly fast when scientists
tried to simulate just one second of a
human brains abilities it took
supercomputers 40 minutes to do so so
yeah I mean the brain isn't we each are
heir to this amazing birthright yeah I
know forged over millions of million you
know millions and millions of years of
life on earth and yet the modern world
is fighting it at every turn you know
from the toxic industrial products that
have saturated the food supply to the
dietary advice that we've been given
for decades - now the fact of the
pendulum sort of swing in the other
direction and people are it's sort of
like a dietary free-for-all you know
yeah so all right let's shift okay my
dietary yes I want to talk about your
asset so you know that at the moment I'm
in the middle of this sort of slow carb
diet this high fat no sugar no car yes
diet
I've actually in about as of this taping
in about nine days I've lost about three
pounds but I actually feel pretty good I
have these like brief moments where I
want to punch random people I think I'm
being a little meaner on Twitter than I
really would be for real I mean like
there is just like a little bit of mood
stuff but my energy feels pretty good
I'm not getting that sort of crash from
coffee that you might get it like two
o'clock but then has people drinking all
kinds of chemicals that after their 2:30
feeling or whatever that is right
so I basically feel pretty good it's
pretty much just meat and fishing and
veggies and a lot of butter and you said
you said to me right before we started
maybe but maybe the butter isn't great
grass-fed butter
yeah well grass-fed butter is definitely
good you know I mean there's definitely
trace nutrients in it vitamin k2 which
we talked about earlier CLA which is
being studied as a potential cancer
fighter and fat burner but it's a you
know one of the hallmarks of a healthy
food is nutrient density when you take
any concentrated fat you know butter oil
they're not very nutrient dense they've
got a lot of calories 9 calories per
gram a tablespoon of oil has 140
calories and and yeah and it's just it's
a lot of calories with very little
nutrients and there's you know on butter
alone there's not a lot of evidence to
say that butter improves fat burning or
brain health or anything like that so
you know I like to tell people that you
know consuming fat the the high fat low
carb diet if you already have fat all
you need is a low carb you know your
body has the fat to burn right so this
body's gonna go to your fat probably in
your stomach area yeah as opposed to
what a lot of people are doing with
these diets is you're loading up on fat
to sort of get the burn going on fat and
then the hope is that then it yeah you
see your fat your body's gonna want to
burn the fat that you're consuming
before it burns the fat that you have
around your waist and the point of a
diet like this I would assume is to lose
some of the fat
your around your waist yeah I mean
that's why I think this conversation is
so interesting because I you know
Ferriss Tim Ferriss is the one that sort
of did the slow carb thing or the 4-hour
body whatever it is and it's like well
alright he's focusing on that part the
weight-loss part so I am seeing some
results on that from yeah you're
focusing on the brain part which is also
very important to me you know idiot I'm
someone I'd like to know what I'm
talking about to be able to have clean
thoughts and all that of course I like
to I mean I like to focus on the weight
part too I mean that's a you know it's a
concern for I think everybody and it's a
good way also to just have this
conversation about nutrition and healthy
eating you know when you start a low
carb diet gonna lose a lot of water
weight at first because what you're
doing is you're depleting the amount of
glycogen stored in your muscles glycogen
is basically how your muscles and liver
store sugar but for every gram of
glycogen that your muscles store you
also store about 3 to 4 grams of water
so that's why once you start depleting
the glycogen from your muscles with
vigorous exercise or just by not eating
a lot of carbs you lose a lot of water
weight very quickly and that's also why
when people stop you know eating low
carb and go back to eating a higher carb
diet their waitress shoots up because
their muscles end up storing all that
glycogen along with all that you know
with four parts water for every one gram
one part of of sugar stored I think what
we're gonna have to do is like in a
month from now if I can keep running
with this thing I'll have to have you
and Ferris on together you guys got like
poked me you can poke my brain area you
can poke my stomach will figure out
sounds great what happened here alright
so enough about my my diet people I
guess we'll see the result right here on
the YouTube okay so you you start
realizing that the the medicine for
dementia or Alzheimer's these cognitive
degenerative diseases is not quite there
you start changing your own diet but
then also realize well this is how I can
also sort of help my mom and help other
people like this so what are some of the
first things that you realized that we
as people of generally are doing wrong
yeah well definitely you know my diet
used to be dictated by you know what
sort of conventional wisdom was
surrounding a healthy diet so I used to
build my you know base my diet around
grains I used to basically shun white
carbs you know white rice white bread as
if it were some kind of toxin but if you
put a huge bowl of brown rice and in
front of me
go to town on it often asking for
seconds you know every meal had to
include a grain and I would notice that
my energy levels throughout the day
always felt like a roller coaster you
know I couldn't really go many hours
after waking without eating something
right away and in between lunch and
dinner I was off I would often find
myself starving and you know when I
started looking into the research I
realized that there's really no good
evidence to say that grains improve
health I mean certainly if you're
metabolically healthy you can tolerate
grains which is not the case for 50% of
the people living in America that are
either either pre-diabetic or diabetic
and have essentially become glucose or
carbohydrate intolerant if you're
healthy though you can eat you know rice
and you could certainly incorporate it
as a means of an you know improving
athletic performance but that was like
really the first thing that I did you
know because my diet was never very high
and added sugars I started cutting out
the breads and the Rice's and all that
stuff and the pastas and I noticed that
my energy levels just you know not only
did they go through the roof but they
were more stable throughout the day and
you know without even really trying my
body composition changed I started you
know losing fat which is something that
was just like a side bonus and again you
know the recommendations to eat grains
because many people do consider them
healthy you know how could quinoa brown
rice bean is about healthy come from
misguided you know nutrition policy over
the past 50 years that have really been
attributed to the Mediterranean dietary
pattern that's this nebulous idea of how
people in the Mediterranean eat because
epidemiological research observational
population-based research shows that
they have reduced rates of
cardiovascular disease and neurological
disease but when you look at randomized
control trials which are the kinds of
trials required to prove cause and
effect
there's no good evidence to say that
grains improve health in fact when you
look at research control trials with
people with pre-diabetes or type 2
diabetes or obesity low-carb diets seem
to win most of the time when compared to
standard low fat you know conventional
was conventional dietary wisdom yeah so
let's back up for a second because
you said something really interesting
that just sort of rolled off your tongue
it seems pretty freakin daggering and
scary 50% of Americans are either
pre-diabetic or diabetic yeah that's
what the latest statistics so what is
actually what is pre-diabetic actually
mean so when you're pre-diabetic you're
your blood sugar is higher than it
should be
that's what a doctor will measure and
they'll say you should probably you know
change up your diet because you are at
risk for becoming a type-2 diabetic it's
sort of like this middle ground where
yeah your blood sugar is higher than it
should be do they know how much that
number has changed over the years I
suspect since probably the 50s when we
started all this processed food and
sugars and all that stuff that that and
soft drinks never you know that must
have tremendously increase that number
yeah I mean it's it's skyrocketed in
tandem with you know the obesity rates
in this country 60s two thirds of people
are either overweight or obese and
they've kind of you know risen in tandem
with one another and the only thing that
can really explain it is the environment
you know because our genes certainly
haven't changed over the past 100 years
as a as a population so what has well
the food supply and you know there's a
lot of zealotry in the world of
nutrition it's a very you know people
tend to feel very religious of other
nutritious beliefs but you know in
general what I think most people would
agree on is that there's become a
ubiquity of hyper processed foods that
are rich in both readily easily
digestible carbohydrates pulverized
grains stripped of their nutrients and
added fats and you know both of these
foods put together basically create a
stereotypical junk food and that's
really what most people are consuming
these days I mean 60% of calories and
Americans consume come from these exact
kinds of foods ultra-processed foods I
always think of that commercial I don't
know if they're still running it but
it's with Larry the Cable Guy for
prilosec otc
yeah and you know he's out there eating
the hotdogs and all this stuff and he's
basically like you can eat whatever you
want as long as I have your prilosec otc
i just take like it's like the pill is
the answer you know he's a pretty heavy
guy in the first place I have no problem
with him but it's like that that we
go to do whatever the hell you want and
then here's our magic pill for it
probably not the best way to be dealing
with them not know not the best way at
all I mean and the thing is you know
once you've one of the main drivers of
of type 2 diabetes and insulin
resistance which category which is one
of the sort of which is the hallmark of
type 2 diabetes is chronically elevated
levels of insulin which could precede a
diagnosis of even pre-diabetes by a
decade so I mean people are walking
around eating on average 300 grams of
carbohydrates per day exactly from the
kinds of foods that we're talking about
hyper processed foods and it's just
doing a number on our metabolisms our
waste lines and you know ingenious foods
we explore you know what it's doing to
our brains and our mental function and
our moods yeah all right so that's
really where I want to focus on this
because I think that's your expertise
and I just find that fascinating cuz I
think there's a lot of things happening
right now that might be changing some of
our brain chemistry and how we think and
and all that sort of stuff
yeah so at any point when this was
happening with your mom did any doctor
say maybe she should change her diet no
that really not once yeah and again I've
been to all that the most storied you
know us news and you know whatever that
the annual you know ranking of hospitals
in America is and we were we went to the
top hospitals to try to find a diagnosis
and not once was diet mentioned at all
and you know there's there's not
conclusive evidence on how diet can
affect somebody who has the disease
although it's starting to bubble up in
the in the literature but yeah I mean
you know exercise wasn't really
mentioned even though exercise is one of
the best ways to treat you know one of
the actually the the right the the
guidelines for treating mild cognitive
impairment were literally just updated
two weeks ago to you know to include
exercise as a means of treatment for
people with mild cognitive impairment
which is sort of like pre dementia which
often converts to you know diseases like
Alzheimer's disease but yeah so I became
I became fixated on on these sort of
alternate approaches to treatment and
even possibly prevention when I went up
when I had that
experience with my mom because I've
always been a big believer in the power
of diet and lifestyle just seen it play
out in my own life I mean I go to the
gym and I'm a different person walking
out of the gym
and I am walking into the gym yeah I
mean whatever cobwebs I have in my head
are gone you know excised like the
demons you know are excised with a good
workout and yet you know that's not
something that I feel like is common
wisdom so when this all happens my mom I
started you know researching and I
realized that there's a lot of you know
insight out there both in terms of risk
factors for developing dementia you know
for example take the Mediterranean
dietary pattern which we talked about
before which is associated with reduced
risks of many chronic diseases yeah can
you explain what that is basically a lot
a lot of oils yeah so it's like
characterized by being really high in
extra-virgin olive oil
you know a glass of wine per day for
women wants to for men and then the way
that it's typically defined in the
medical literature is as being a it's
it's defined as being a grain based diet
and it all stems back from you know this
one epidemiologist named Ancel Keys who
basically in the 1950s stationed himself
on the island of Crete to look at how
that population basically ate and went
about their lives in the midst of a
major epidemic of heart disease in the
United States he wanted to see you know
what they were doing differently in the
Mediterranean region of the world that
we might be able to glean some
nutritional insight but the problem is
he and this is a story that's been told
by you know other people there's a
there's a great book called the big fat
surprise with you know the journalist
who wrote it really goes into depth on
the story but I talked about it as well
ingenious foods you know he was
stationed on the island during Lent so
it was a particularly lean time just
after world war ii and his observation
of their dietary pattern was one where
you know it was it was predominantly
grain based but people in the
mediterranean region they loved fatty
cuts of meat you know I have friends
were born there and who visit you know
very frequently and they eat very fatty
cuts of you know meat lamb for example
yeah yeah that's all but ignored in the
medical textbook definition of the
Mediterranean diet and also when you're
observing a population as
what it is that they're eating it's
impossible to ascribe causality to any
dietary element because what you're
observing is basically you're you're
doing just that you're observing
variables but without doing a randomized
control trial it's impossible to prove
which aspects of that diet are causally
related to the you know the phenotypes
the outcomes that you're seeing in terms
of the population health right
so so that and that could partly also
just because of geography and lifestyle
whether the amount they move around yeah
if it's cold you might need a little
more fat on your bones exactly you don't
know so you need a randomized control
trial to do that so what I what I argue
in the book is that well you know what
you see in terms of the health of people
living in that region of the world is
not because of the grains that they're
eating but in spite of the grains that
they're eating because when you actually
look at what greens are you know it's a
whole lot of starch wrapped in a little
bit of insoluble fiber and a tiny amount
of vitamins when building a you know a
healthy diet we want to really look for
things that are nutrient-dense that the
brain needs so well you know one of the
recommendations that I make to people
generally is to consume a huge salad a
fatty salad every single day rather than
eating a bowl of brown rice which is
pretty nutritionally sparse dark leafy
greens contain a bevy of micronutrients
that the brain actually needs to create
energy and there's really good research
actually a study was just published from
Rush University that found that people
that consume a large bowl of dark leafy
greens per day have brains that look on
scans 11 years younger so yeah so I mean
there's um and you also realized with
some of this stuff that it you're not
missing much actually I mean it's just
in this you know week and whatever that
I'm doing this diet I got a poke a bowl
yesterday and I usually get brown rice
on the bottom but I got the leafy greens
instead and I actually in a way I
enjoyed it more and I felt kind of
slimmer after because yeah you're just
taking it all that right well you're
gonna feel much better I mean your body
you know makes a lot of effort to keep
certain things within a very narrow
margin so for example your your body
temperature is one of those things that
your body works really hard to keep with
you know hovering at around ninety eight
point six degrees right the same thing
with your blood sugar
given time you've got you know one
teaspoon of circulating sugar in your
body and your pancreas works very hard
to keep your circulating blood sugar at
that level the minute you eat a massive
bowl of brown rice or drink you know a
glass of orange juice which so many
Americans begin their day with which
contains about 6 to 7 teaspoons of pure
sugar your that's like a deluge of
glucose being shuttled straight into
your blood that the vast majority of
people don't need where is that sugar
gonna go most likely it's gonna end up
on your hips and on your waist yeah so
basically soft drinks I mean I think
everyone sort of knows this and drinks
it despite the knowledge or at least the
knowledge is is readily accessible so
options are pretty much the worst thing
you can drink right I mean the amount of
sugar there is just anything horrible
yeah I mean there's no you know
requirement for consuming added sugar a
lot of people actually feel that they
need sugar to fuel their brain because
of the boost and executive function that
they feel you know after consuming a
food that's sugary or you know a granola
bar or you know any car bridge food but
really so many people are hooked on
glucose as a fuel for the brain that in
reality what they're doing is they're
treating their withdrawal from sugar
from the previous meal and that's why
they feel boost so basically you have a
soda at lunch and then you you're having
that crash like two hours later and
you're like oh I need that bar that has
exactly yeah and it tricks you tricks
but I mean it's it's there's a good
reason that you feel tricked and that
you feel like these foods are your
friends because you know when you're on
that sort of glucose rollercoaster
throughout the day you need those
constant pick-me-ups and that's the
problem so what I think you know is a
more sustainable way of having energy
cognitive resilience is to step off of
that that train the glucose train and
really recreate yourself with healthy
fats and foods that are much lower in
carbohydrates and much richer in the
nutrients that your brain actually needs
all right I want to get down to all the
things we should be eating we talked
about green leafy things yeah
but there's a lot more to it than that
that's what a lot of this is about so
let's get to it if you want to someone's
watching this right now
yeah maybe they're eating poorly maybe
they're eating okay maybe they think
they're doing a pretty good job but they
want to just kind of reset yeah take
them from beat one yeah so I mean I
think the first thing that people should
do is really cut out the processed foods
which is harder than it seems you know
and and I definitely my heart goes out
to people that feel like they can't give
up the junk food because again you know
these foods are not designed to be
consumed in moderation the advice to eat
everything in moderation is horrible in
the modern world in the modern
supermarket literally our our
supermarket aisles are lined with foods
that are designed by scientists that are
paid a lot more than you and I - to
create insatiable overconsumption and
addiction yeah wait let's let's focus on
that because it sounds like it's not
true but it's actually true like they
actually have people working on isn't
this what they did with Doritos
originally I think okay think that they
I mean that Cool Ranch flavor
I usually just literally - I literally
used to just lick those kids you don't
want to eat your fingers yeah yeah yeah
so there are literally scientists
working for these companies making you
want more and more and more absolutely
these foods you know net which now make
up again 60% of the calories consumed in
the US are designed to screw up your
brain and usually what happens is the
scientists will combine some parts sugar
wheat usually with fat and salt and it
creates this this unique mixture of
delict able you know mouthfeel as well
as just you know the the the exact
sensation that we've evolved basically
to seek out more of it just sets off
dopamine fireworks in our brains is that
actually the same thing that happens to
your brain when you do drugs and then
you need more drugs I mean is it really
the same chemical reactions that are
happening yeah absolutely if not worse I
mean they've done Studies on on animals
rats for example which are all in
basically in rats provide a really great
look into the behavior that certain
foods drive because you know they've got
no super-ego to steer them from what is
it they really want to do they're all
it'd so they've shown that rats actually
prefer sugar to cocaine which is funny
because whereas really like cocaine yeah
rats really like cocaine they really
like cocaine yeah but um no I mean we
tend to
think you know of ourselves as having
had like a moral failure right like when
we go through a whole bag of chips or
like eat the whole pint of ice cream but
again like these foods are not designed
to be consumed in moderation they're
designed literally to have you finish
that whole pint or that whole bag and
then go back as a repeat customer yeah I
always think the branding of it is so
funny to like you see all these things
like guilt-free chips
yeah or don't feel bad about how fat you
are it's what any of this stuff and it's
like it's all this weird psychological
play to get you to keep eating oh yes no
once you pop you can't stop it's like a
truism with scientific backing yeah at
this point all right so the the reset
person that's watching this right now
that's gonna start doing some yeah okay
get the process stuff out and that
includes like that's pretty much all the
stuff that you see in the frozen section
yeah like like all of that frozen
breakfast stuff and all those sandwiches
and all definitely and actually you know
a really good recommendation for people
that are really trying to make this
change is to first actually which is
kind of counterintuitive but to work on
your sleep sleep I like to say allows a
person getting good quality adequate
sleep gives a person the hormonal
fortitude to make those dietary changes
so when you you know when your
underslept actually a study was just put
out showing that people tend to over
consume and eat excess calories
predominantly from these exact kinds of
foods so yeah optimizing sleep and then
what do they say on sleep like is it
eight hours really is that what they
want for like the average yeah eight
hours is a good amount and then it's
that's also roughly the amount of sleep
that you need to maximize growth hormone
which is an important hormone in the
body for preserving lean mass but yeah I
mean in quality sleep as well so I mean
not just getting those eight hours but
making sure that those eight hours are
really you know super high quality and
we can get into ways of optimizing sleep
I guess one of them one of the best ways
that I like to optimize my sleep and I
find it to be very effective is to limit
my exposure to
screens at night because what time do
you shut down yeah I mean I shut down I
try to shut down two to three hours
before bed or if I if I'm not shutting
down and I have to work up until the
point of which you know I go to bed I
mean let's face it living in the real
world you know sometimes we have to
respond to an urgent email I use blue
light blocking glasses mm-hmm
which I'm a big fan of actually and
there's good research on Amburg colored
glasses and their ability to sort of
mitigate some of the loss of melatonin
do you know is that the same effect that
the iPhone has now with their night
thing is that that same thing I'm not
sure that I'm filtering yeah yeah I'm
not sure if it's comparable actually I
mean I'd feel it certainly feels way
better to my eyes when night shift is on
but yeah I mean I noticed that when I so
in my house in New York I've got it's my
brothers I live with my brother he has a
massive TV it's like 85 inches or just
one of the biggest monsters in
television I've ever seen in my life
and you know he likes to watch movies up
until the point at which he goes to bed
and that's not my preference but I do
that with him sometimes and I will watch
like a movie up until like midnight or
something and I notice that when I have
that amount of light pouring into my
face when I go to bed right after that
I'll oftentimes actually wake up feeling
hungover even though I've never I've had
the eight hours of sleep and I hadn't
had any alcohol
I just feel under slept and not
rejuvenated whereas when I wear the blue
light lugging glasses and I have no you
know I'm not uh you know formally
affiliated with any of these companies I
don't manufacture them in any sense but
uh but I do find that they work I wait I
wake up feeling a lot more refreshed
well I well I think that the digital
piece of this is so interesting because
I talk about it with almost every guest
like just the frustration with social
media and not putting this stuff down in
digital addiction and and all of this
and it's like one of the things that
I've tried to do is I never bring my
phone into my room any more beds more I
just stopped doing it cuz I realized wow
right before I go to bed I'm looking at
my phone and then literally the first
thing I do when I wake up yeah before I
brush my teeth before I go to the
bathroom is I'm suddenly looking at my
phone again like even if it's all
wonderful news it's probably not and
it's usually not yeah but even if it was
it's probably not a great way to start
saying so that and I've really really
been trying to do no technology on the
weekends and I think and I think that
that's really helped so is there some
sort of connection between all of that
and and like just the digit
monster that's affecting iodine - yeah I
mean there's no yellow just like yeah
something else happy well yeah I mean I
think from a mood standpoint for sure I
mean like you know our stress response
evolved at a time when things that were
stressful to us required our immediate
attention right so cycle air yeah like a
bear in your face yeah like this like
protracted long-term psychological
stress though that so many of us have
you know so commonly today is a fairly
new invention in on the evolutionary
timescale
and the media for example knows this and
like not developer app developers know
this that's why I like you turn on any
you know news station local news
especially they abide by the if it
bleeds it leads mentality put the most
anxiety inducing segments up front or
tease at it at least so that it causes
an expression of or an upregulation of
norepinephrine in the brain which is
basically the brain's focus and
attention neurotransmitter associated
with stress and that's something that
you know in it makes you more alert
makes you feel more awake and so when
you read you know doom and gloom news on
your on your smartphone you're basically
having the same exact stress response
yeah it's funny how when you step away
from it a little bit to how silly it
almost seems so like when I get away on
the weekend and then I'm back on Monday
if I look back at anything that might
have happened and I see all these people
fight I'm like wow you all spent your
weekend just fighting about this stuff
it's one thing that we're doing it on
the weekdays and maybe we can all manage
that myself included maybe we can all
manage that a little differently that
endless sort of yeah way out thing it's
it's a lot it also yeah I mean I'm not
as familiar with the there was this
there was a study that came out showing
that just having your smartphone around
you is exhausting from a cognitive
standpoint you know just sort of having
it around and sort of feeling that pole
we get addicted to it I mean it sort of
you know hijacks our dopamine systems as
well you know being addicted to social
media that's a real thing yeah it's
interesting to me though because people
watch this show and we know what our
watch times are and they're off the
charts for for YouTube which usually has
like a seven second watch time or
something and that shows to me that
people want long-form they
we want something that isn't so
insulting to their senses to their brain
now ironically many people are watching
this right now or listening on their
phones but a lot of people listen on
their phones while they're doing
exercise or while they're commuting is
like but I do sense that people want
something else so it's like the news is
giving us the local news as you're
saying they're giving us something we
don't want because they know it'll keep
us there but food companies are giving
us something that's not good for us
because they know it'll keep us there we
now know Tristan Harris who I've had on
talked about how the tech companies and
you just alluded to this are giving us
things that they know are bad first so
it really is your job yeah it's like a
full-time job now as a human to be like
I'm gonna do the things that actually
argued for me not the things you keep
feeding well exactly and you know that's
why I think it's such a shame because we
each are heir to this amazing gift right
the human brain yet the modern world is
like The Hunger Games right like
attacking it from every which way
and we are not equipped with the tools
to understand you know what to do to
sort of fix that situation
yeah and so yeah I mean I definitely
recommend people taking a break you know
from social media from news the 24-hour
news cycle I think is just not healthy
and then also certainly food you know I
think food is a major part of it
lifestyle you know one of the things
that I talk about in the book we go into
depth is the fact that you know not only
are we more sedentary than we've ever
been not getting enough exercise but you
know there's a there was another form of
exercise that we all had for the
majority of our evolution and that is
thermal exercise you know today we live
in a time where you know there's chronic
climate control you know and that's
something that seems to be to the
detriment of our metabolisms so I talked
about how you can use you know cold
showers to enhance vigilance which is
one of the few things that you can do
that you actually feel a shift in your
consciousness are you big on that people
they're these people that like jump from
like the hot tub to a freezing cold I do
that yeah yeah wait maybe it was you
that I thought you were you took a
picture like in a pool or something yeah
yeah it must've been you die think the
first time I saw it so what is that so
you jump in from hot water to cold water
and your system is just like constantly
rebooting
well it's called contrast therapy so
basically you know and your and a lot of
the mechanisms are sort of conserved
between the two activities so you know
when you go into a cold when you go into
like a sauna for example you're
activating something called heat shock
proteins which are there to sort of
guard the proteins in your body against
disfigurement which is really important
because a lot of the diseases that we're
talking about Alzheimer's disease
Parkinson's disease are associated with
misfolded proteins so anytime we can
sort of activate these heat shock
proteins seems to be helpful
they're also activated when you expose
yourself to cold air yeah there's really
good there's really good research a lot
of people now are practicing cryotherapy
as a means of enhancing you know
vigilance reducing inflammation boosting
metabolism increasing the proliferation
of brown fat we all have a kind of fad
in us that it wasn't thought that adults
carried it with them past you know
childhood or infancy but now we know
that we actually have this sort of fat
that's actually a good fat a fat that we
want more of because it's metabolically
active and it burns calories so by going
into cold and being and keeping
ourselves exposed to you know it
intermittent cooler temperatures we
actually encourage the the proliferation
of this hat which is really cool so I
thought by moving to LA and being an
eighty degrees Saturday was good that
was a good thing I guess it's good for
my vitamin D but that's not good for
some of this other stuff yeah yes I so I
think getting back to that you know
having a little bit more thermal stress
in our lives is important they've done
really good research on people with type
2 diabetes and have found that you know
even mild cold below you know or higher
I should say than then what would be
like a freezing temperature does improve
insulin sensitivity which is sort of the
hallmark of metabolic health which is
really interesting it's a way to improve
your health without even doing anything
I mean you basically just turn the dial
on your air conditioner down a little
bit more yeah alright so now let's
circle back okay okay this person starts
that word this imaginary person that
we're talking about that's watching
right now I'm going R I'm going to
incorporate some of the stuff yes
they're gonna get the the Eggos leg oh
my they're gonna get that out of the way
processed food in the morning right what
are they replacing that with for
breakfast yeah so I mean
start this day okay let's start the day
well first of all there is no biological
need for breakfast so let's just get you
know get that out of the picture but I
thought breakfast was the most important
meal of the day the meal that you break
your fast with is important but there's
no biological need to eat as soon as you
wake up so whether you push that first
meal an hour after you wake up or two
hours after you wake up you should be
able to do that I mean breakfast is a
fairly new construct you know in the
evolutionary sense and also when you
wake up first thing in the morning your
body has a really unique hormonal milieu
where it wants to burn fat you know
cortisol is at its highest it Peaks
immediately after you wake up and
cortisol is sort of like the body's fat
burning hormone it's the body's chief
catabolic hormone liberates stored fatty
acids sugars proteins and sort of throw
breakfast into that equation especially
in the most commonly the most commonly
consumed form of it which is you know as
you said like a Lego an eggo waffle yeah
no offense there go and Doritos before
you know weird is naming some things
here yeah yeah what for the person
though that wants to have you know
something in the morning fat and fiber
and protein
so you know eggs are a perfect food to
eat first thing in the morning a
scramble for example with some spinach
kale and some extra virgin olive oil or
you can use a little bit of coconut oil
that's a you know great eat an avocado
oh those are two good oils because every
I feel like every year someone says
grapeseed oils good now I know you I saw
on your website get rid of the great yes
well nothing to do with grapeseed oil
okay no problem yes but when you're
cooking you so basically you're saying
coconut oil or coconut oil is good yeah
you can actually cook with that extra
virgin olive oil it maintains you know
it doesn't oxidize the way some of these
awful grain and seed oils will corn oil
soybean oil canola oil grapeseed oil
these are the worst yeah that's
basically like the smoke point part
right where it becomes actually
interestingly and this is a question I
get asked a lot smoke point and the
temperature at which and on oil oxidizes
there there's no relationship so smoke
point is something that's like a
culinary concern more than anything else
and in fact these oils like canola oil
corn oil soybean oil are so heavily
processed in order for them
have a high smoke point but actually
they become rancid at much lower
temperatures whereas you take a you know
like a fat like butter butter will start
to smoke pretty early on but it's not
because of the fat oxidizing it's
because of the proteins and the KC and
you know the trace lactose and casein
found in butter but that actually has no
bearing on whether or not it's good or
bad for you
so basically though if you were making
you know an egg yeah you some use some
kale and spinach you're talking about
olive oil you're talking about coconut
oil use some water or butter yeah yeah
exactly yeah because you know the more
saturated an oil is the more chemically
stable it's gonna be at higher
temperatures so higher heat cooking you
want to use coconut oil butter ghee lard
tallow things like that my coffee right
now it's got ghee at MCT oil and and
collagen in it it doesn't really taste
like coffee anymore but it's not bad
collagen is awesome I did a great you
know article deep dive into the health
benefits of collagen on my website and
MCT oil is great I don't you know I
don't really see people that have no
idea MCT oil it's it's like an extract
of coconut oil yes yeah so MCT oil is
digested differently than other fats it
basically goes straight to the liver and
it becomes converted to ketones which
are a sort of alternate fuel that the
brain will readily use when they're
available and there's some really
interesting research on MCT as a
potential intervention for for patients
with Alzheimer's disease it might
theoretically help people sort of wean
themselves off of carbs by sort of
supplementing brain energy and yeah it
could also you know I think just in
terms of making you feel like you've had
something first thing in the morning
slowing the release of caffeine into
your bloodstream no that's great but
again you want to be careful with the
added fats because they're very they're
not nutrient dense and they're trying to
lose weight there's no need to add a ton
of oils to your diet I know that's the
irony of where I'm at with this thing
not to make this about it but like I
somehow actually have lost a couple
pounds while doing this very high-fat
thing but I hear what you're saying yeah
I actually probably could cut down on
that and then my body will go to the
actual instead of the fat I'm putting in
there and I don't break it to you but
the weight that you lost could be
at the same time so yeah adding adding
you know oils to the dog water to break
that okay so you have the you have
basically an omelet something to that
effect in the morning yeah with some
greens in there or you'll Bert full fat
yogurt grass-fed yogurt you know that's
something that I think is great can we
explain why grass-fed is so important
because I feel like there's a certain
set of people that are always kind of
like you know you go to get grabbed out
you brass bed like that doesn't do
anything it's no well it dictates the
healthiness of the fat you know so if
you're talking about like grass-fed whey
protein for example makes much less of a
difference because whey protein is just
pure protein but if you're talking about
you know a piece of red meat or
something grass-fed red meat compared to
grain fed red meat it's a different
animal even though it's a same animal
it's basically I mean one in grass-fed
red meat you have a ratio of omega-6
fats to omega-3 fats that basically
mirrors that of the human brain you've
got a lot more carotenoids which are
basically these fat soluble antioxidant
compounds that have been shown to boost
processing speed in the brain which is
really important cows that eat grass
grass contains these carotenoids
carotenoids which are fat soluble they
become embedded in the fat of the cow
and so when you eat a piece of steak
from a cow that's been grass-fed you're
eating those carotenoids along with fat
that helps you absorb it because they
need fat to be absorbed so I mean it's a
really healthy food when you you know
when we're talking about grass-fed meat
and then in terms of yogurt grass-fed
yogurt you know full fat can have you
know a few omega-3s it's not a major
source but it's got CLA vitamin k2 much
higher in grass-fed in the fat of
grass-fed full fat yogurt than you know
conventional yogurt
I feel like lunch is the hard one for a
lot of people cuz at work a lot of
people are barely leaving their desks
yeah at work even for me you know
working from home even but I'm so busy
during the day it's like I we just got
to grab something or get Chipotle or
whatever it is what can you do in the
midday you can have a relatively healthy
meal at Chipotle
I mean Chipotle still you know I think
in all of their options has uses you
know
one of those oils you know green and you
know probably canola oil
I'm not exam but yeah I mean you can get
guacamole there which is certainly very
healthy avocado is incredible for you
it's again packed with carotenoids on
avocado has twice the potassium of a
banana which is amazing people think
about potassium they only think about
bananas very low carb food you can get
some protein and then the salsa I think
is fine you know so you can and the bell
peppers are great but generally like
what I tell people for lunch is it's a
great opportunity during the day to eat
a salad I think people should be eating
a large salad every single day again the
research is pretty compelling and you
know mechanistically it makes sense that
dark leafy greens would be really good
for a person they're the most nutrient
dense foods there are meaning there's
tons of nutrients for very few calories
they're packed with dietary fiber which
you know will not only help fill you up
but it feeds the microorganisms that
live in your large intestine this is
called the microbiome which is a really
exciting focus now in research and you
want to make that salad fat and I don't
mean by putting you know tortilla strips
and ranch dressing and cheese on it or
even commercial salad dressings you
really want to avoid those but there's
no better vehicle for extra virgin olive
oil than a salad and extra virgin olive
oil going back to the Mediterranean
dietary pattern it's a hallmark and
they've done research
you know randomized control trials where
they look specifically at extra-virgin
olive oil one of the you know the sort
of best studies to to look at was done
out of Barcelona Spain called the pretty
med study where they gave subjects a
leader of extra-virgin olive oil extra
virgin olive oil to consume per week and
they found that you know at the end of I
think the trial went on for six years
they had improved cognitive function
they had improved risk factors for
cardiovascular disease and they even
lost weight so by adding more fat to
their diet they ended up losing weight
although it was extra-virgin olive oil
it wasn't butter right okay so now we've
had the omelet started the bay we've had
a big green leafy salad for lunch maybe
some protein in there yeah what's
happening for dinner
yeah so for dinner I'm a big fan of
grass-fed you know red meat I think
that's one of the more
tips that I give people because meat you
know sort of been in the doghouse for so
long but I thought one day a week I read
meat no I mean the thing is I don't
there's no you know there was a really
great study performed by a Charlotte
Newman at UCLA where they gave it was
again a randomized control trial they
gave children in Kenya
this traditional porridge dish made of
beans and green beans and things like
that
you know what a control group had just
the sort of vegetarian version and they
gave a group the version with dairy and
they gave a group a version with meat
and they found that the kids that were
given the version with supplemented meat
added meat actually at the end of the
trial had improved cognitive function
and signs of mental health so there's
other research actually from that
eyesight ingenuous foods from Australia
Deakin University where they found that
women who didn't consume the nationally
recommended 3 to 4 servings of red meat
per week actually had twice the risk for
depression or an anxiety or mood
disorder and so you know I think it's
there's a what's called like a u-shaped
curve I think definitely some red meat
is better than none but eating too much
isn't great either you definitely want
to have a diet that's rich in vegetables
dark leafy greens kale spinach things
like that but in that context I think
that eating properly raised meat is
definitely definitely healthy fatty fish
for dinner would be another another
option fish is packed with
micronutrients that the brain needs to
create new cells which we now know the
adult brain can do up until death and
yeah I mean a you know there's there's a
lot of options I think you know when you
look at a plate you want to have half of
it vegetables and half of it meat
I don't think eating one of the I think
incorrect interpretations of the Paleo
diet is that it's meant to be a really
high meat diet I think that ignores a
lot of the research now again
surrounding the microbiome which is this
area that's very new but you know we
want to get a good you know amount of
dietary fiber micronutrients which the
brain needs
and there's no better way to do that
than with than with veggies so how often
do you cheat on this stuff because I'm
guessing a certain amount of people are
watching this going alright this is what
this guy does for a living yeah he's
writing books about it you know I mean
he has the the time to prepare meals the
way he wants it cetera et cetera how
often do you go off the deep end and you
know a couple times a year but you know
I think I think God have the cravings
for that's the no I don't scream I don't
to be totally honest and I I've always
had a huge sweet tooth but I yeah I
don't really once I made the transition
to a lower carb diet I don't have those
cravings in fact I can comfortably go
hours without eating I think that's a
really good subjective sign of metabolic
resilience what about alcohol where does
that fit in says I know you mentioned
the one glass of wine for a woman what
are they why don't I have to do once to
four men per day yeah is that basically
aligned with what you're yeah I mean
there's you know some researchers
recommend you know consuming red wine
it's part of the sort of mind diet which
is a dietary sort of pattern that was
created at Rush University but I don't
you know I think I think it's hard to
study alcohol because on the one hand
it's such a powerful social lubricant
and feeling connected to one another and
of course you know as a solvent for
stress I think it's really powerful and
that's not to be discounted you know we
live stressful lives and there's sort of
no way around that for for many people
but Ethel is a neurotoxin and I think if
you're if you have a way of dealing with
stress and feeling connected with you
know with one another without it I think
you're probably better off doing that
but I do give some tips in the book
about how to make consuming alcohol as
healthy and experiences as possible you
want to avoid sugary mixers I think beer
is you know one of the least healthiest
alcohols that you can consume you always
want to follow the one-for-one rule you
know chase every drink with a glass of
water and also you know alcohol is a
diuretic and when you pee a lot you
excrete sodium and so by replenishing
those electrolytes
you know while you're drinking I think
that's really important so sprinkle a
little a little bit of salt in your
water for example could be one way to do
that right people don't realize that
like you don't need it down a Gatorade
just cuz you lost a couple electrolytes
literally just a little salt in your
water a little bit of salt yeah I
actually became have become really
interested in salt I yeah I carry a
little vial of salt in my gym bag now
and after a good sauna session or
workout I sprinkle a little bit in my
mouth yeah yeah Wow
yeah because you lose you lose great
people they're not gonna be happy that
they're not gonna be happy about that
you lose especially when you're on a
low-carb diet when you drop the carbs
your insulin comes down and insulin
basically tells the kid needs to hold on
to sodium you know unnaturally so for
people that are on a really high carb
diet which most most Americans are
consuming 300 grams of carbs a day with
insulin levels constantly elevated
they're holding on to excess sodium so
the recommendation to watch your sodium
intake in that sort of context makes a
lot of sense but if you're eating a low
carb diet as you should focused on you
know Whole Foods that are not packed
with starch you really need to be
mindful of not only your sodium intake
because again sodium's sodium's a
nutrient it's not this poison that you
know you would think it was looking at
the labels of you know processed foods
that are low in sodium and that's
somehow supposed to make it okay that
you're eating you know tons of sugar and
and and processed wheat yeah so you need
to really be mindful that and then you
do other things in your lifestyle that
that accelerate the the spilling of
sodium so like exercise drinking coffee
which causes you to pee out a lot of
sodium I did a great interview with a
researcher who focuses on this topic and
yeah it's a it's an area of interest for
me and definitely when I when I wake up
in the morning if I'm doing like one of
my really you know particularly low carb
phases I'll sprinkle you know a little
bit of salt in my water and it makes me
feel it gives me like a boost of energy
yeah interesting
all right so let's go full circle here
so basically about six years ago that's
when this all started and yeah and your
mom was diagnosed he obviously changed
her life afterwards changed your life
where's your mom at now and and how have
the things everything we've talked about
to this last hour how
have you been able to incorporate them
into her life and and see see some
changes I mean you know I've I've tried
especially when I moved from LA back to
New York I I really tried to take a you
know super hands-on approach for as long
as I could with my mom to change her
diet and certainly some some aspects of
her diet has changed but you know
dementia is a horrible disease and it
makes it really hard on both the patient
and the caregiver to to adhere to strict
dietary interventions you know there was
a study that I was that I dove into
recently where they put people with
Alzheimer's disease both mild to
moderate Alzheimer's disease on a
ketogenic diet and they found that one
of the major limitations of the study is
that adherence is so high - you know -
these diets and it's a major stress on
the caregiver I'm not my mom's caregiver
but at a certain point I had to kind of
teach and step back you know so that you
know if I am around my mom she's craving
something that you know isn't max
approved it doesn't affect my
relationship with her because first and
foremost I love my mom and you know I
don't want to do anything to compromise
the relationship or her quality of life
so I wonder is there any work done that
people with dementia I can sort of
remember this from my grandmother who
had dementia and I spent a lot of time
with her her last few years that she was
an incredible cook used to cook all
sorts of exotic things but in her later
years as the dementia kicked in she
really only wanted the same few things
is that do you think somehow connected
to like there's just certain things
maybe that are still in the memory like
sorry like she really suddenly wanted
chicken soup all the time mmm but I
don't remember really her having chicken
soup for many years before that she
would cook these crazy meals yeah I mean
the only shift in food preference that
I'm familiar with is a shift towards
sweeter foods which occurs and it's
thought that that happens because a
brain with Alzheimer's disease is
essentially being starved of its you
know one of its primary energy
substrates which is glucose so there's
this notion that Alzheimer's disease is
a form of diabetes of the brain it's
essentially become unable to properly
is glucose that's where ketogenic
interventions have shown a lot of
promise and it's thought that that might
be really helpful for a patient with
Alzheimer's disease and one of the
things that that sort of strengthens
that that notion is that they that
people you know that that perhaps never
expressed a preference for sweet foods
or had a sweet tooth begin to crave
sugar and it saw that that's sort of the
brain crying out for sugar as a means of
creating energy but the irony is that
those are the exact kinds of foods that
drive inflammation and you know insulin
resistance in the body and that are so
detrimental to the brain to begin with
yeah there's really there's really
interesting you know and ketogenic diets
are I think they've become a little buzz
worthy these days and popular but
there's a lot of good research on them
they're hard to study there's not a lot
of money to go around to to really to
study them but there's good evidence
that actually one of my friends
published a study on patients with mild
cognitive impairment we're putting
patients with with mild cognitive
impairment on a ketogenic diet seemed to
improve cognitive function and then just
recently that was extended to patients
with Alzheimer's disease which we were
all waiting for we're all waiting for a
ketogenic trial to be performed on
patients with diagnosed Alzheimer's
disease and it seemed that for the
patients that were able to adhere to it
there was a significant improvement in
their cognitive function when they were
on that diet and they went back to you
know their baseline level of cognitive
function after the trial ended which
really you know strengthens the notion
that ketones were helping the brain sort
of as an energetic life raft it seems
that the main takeaway here is do some
of the preventional work completely
again you know all timers disease begins
in the brain thirty to forty years
before the first symptoms before the
first symptom and there's even some data
suggesting that this could be a lifelong
thing for people with certain genes that
put them at higher risk for Alzheimer's
disease like the apoe4 allele which one
in four people carry yeah well it's a
pleasure to see you you've become a
master of your craft and I think it
maybe has a little something to do with
what you're eating because you're
pulling information pretty quickly so I
think you've the proof is in the
gluten-free pudding or something like
that all right genius boots comes out
March 20th yes yes see I memorized that
that was pretty impressive and breadhead
your documentary that's in the works
right now that's in the works that will
come out at some point this year people
can check out a Kickstarter teaser at
breadhead movie calm yeah we'll link to
that right down below and genius Foods
is is up for pre-order now I mean it's
it's gonna be everywhere books are sold
so thank you all right well it's been a
pleasure I think doing this with you
while I'm in the midst of this diet
you've given me some ways that maybe I
can change it a little less fat and well
we'll revisit this privately in a couple
of months and then and then we'll do
this again for sure awesome things all
right well for more on Macs follow him
on the Twitter it's max Luger b or lu g
AV e re
[Music]
you